en el último vídeo vimos que una
progresión geométrica o también conocida
como sucesión geométrica es una sucesión
que se obtiene de multiplicar cada
número por un número fijo para ir
obteniendo el número consecutivo y a ese
número fijo le llamamos proporción común
y de hecho teníamos un ejemplo aquí que
pintamos en rojo ahí teníamos que
empezamos con el número 3 y después
nuestra proporción común sería el 2 así
que 3 por 2 nos da 6 para obtener el
siguiente número habría que multiplicar
6 por 2 lo cual nos daba 12 y así
podemos seguir indefinidamente para
obtener toda la sucesión muy bien
y algo que quizás no mencioné es que la
proporción común puede ser incluso un
número negativo por ejemplo si tú tienes
el número 1 y digamos que nuestra
proporción común es el menos 3 entonces
1 x menos 3 nos da
-3 si queremos obtener el siguiente
tendríamos que multiplicar menos 3 x
menos 3 y eso nos da 9 para obtener el
siguiente multiplicamos 9 por menos 3 y
eso es menos 27 ya para terminar si
multiplicamos menos 27 por menos 3 nos
da 81 y así podemos seguir tanto como
queramos verdad así que en este vídeo lo
que quiero hacer es enfocarme en qué
pasa si queremos sumar los términos de
una progresión geométrica muy bien
entonces por razones más o menos obvias
a esto es a lo que le vamos a conocer
como serie geométrica serie
y métrica que es una serie geométrica es
simplemente sumar todos los términos de
una progresión geométrica por ejemplo si
quisiéramos calcular la serie o si si
quisiéramos calcular la serie de esta
progresión geométrica geométrica perdón
tendríamos 1 y luego sumamos menos tres
después sumamos el siguiente término que
es 9 y luego sumamos menos 27 seguimos
sumando 81 y así nos seguimos con todos
los términos entonces esto sería una
serie geométrica porque estamos sumando
los términos de una progresión
geométrica si nosotros quisiéramos
calcular la serie geométrica de esta
progresión roja entonces tendríamos 3
+ 6 más 12 más 24 48 y así seguimos con
todos los términos entonces estos dos
son ejemplos de una serie geométrica
algo que deberíamos abordar es bueno
como representamos una serie geométrica
ok en general vamos a tener lo siguiente
tenemos nuestro número que incluso
habíamos denotado con a empezamos con un
número a y sumamos a poner que es el
siguiente término verdad r va a ser
nuestra proporción común el siguiente
término sería a por r cuadrada verdad es
re cuadrada porque multiplicamos este
término por r podemos seguir con un
tercer término digamos a por r al cubo y
podemos seguir con otro término a por r
elevado a la 4 y así seguir sumando
indefinidamente muy bien entonces si
nosotros quisiéramos calcular la serie
geométrica
o más bien la suma geométrica porque
vamos a tener una serie geométrica
finita qué pasa si tenemos una
progresión geométrica finita y sumamos
todos
términos entonces tendríamos una especie
de serie geométrica pero finita que
termina en algún punto digamos cuando
elevamos ere a la n entonces si tomamos
una progresión geométrica y los sumamos
vamos queremos queremos representar esto
en términos por ejemplo de la notación
con la letra griega sigma así que como
representaríamos esto bueno algo que hay
que notar quizás debería darte una pausa
antes para que lo pienses tú y que
puedas después verificar con lo que
terminemos haciendo en este vídeo si si
coincide con lo que tú pensaste
entonces para lograrlo uno podría pensar
que aquí está siendo x r elevado a la
cero y aquí podría uno pensar que a está
multiplicando a r elevado a la 1 y si te
das cuenta en cada uno de los términos
estamos incrementando el exponente de
nuestra proporción común entonces cómo
quedaría esto esto sería la suma
utilizando nuestra letra griega sigma
mayúscula y el exponente que empieza en
cero y termina en n de quien pues
estamos sumando a x r&r va cambiando de
exponente entonces aquí elevamos a la k
entonces puedes darte tu cuenta que a
medida que vamos cambiando la k nos va
dando justo estos términos y esto es una
muy buena forma de representar una serie
geométrica al menos en el caso finito
para poder hacerlo nuestra proporción
común tiene que ser un número distinto
de cero y que como ya vimos incluso
puede ser negativo